14 months after Jamal keshavjee was last
seen walking into the Saudi consulate in
Istanbul where his fiancee hot TJ
jenga's waited four hours before calling
for help
a Saudi Court has issued a verdict the
Criminal Court in Riyadh has issued a
preliminary sentence against eleven of
the accused individuals and it is as
follows
the death penalty for five and they are
those who directly participated in his
killing may he rest in peace
but senior Saudis with close connections
to the Royal Court have been cleared the
court ruled there was no proven
involvement of Saud al Kitani in the
murder he was advisor to Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman before his sacking
soon after keshavjee skilling the
Turkish chief prosecutor's office in
Istanbul filed a warrant for kotani's
arrest a year ago in June the UN special
investigator Agnes calamari said
intelligence agents had identified
Kotani as a hit squad ringleader
I have insisted that the killing of mr.
Khashoggi is a state killing it is not
killing by rogue officials as the
country the government continued to to
pretend at least under international
human rights law and she urged the world
to sanction the crown prince and his
assets until he could prove his
innocence that hasn't happened
exoneration to for former Consul General
Mohammad Allah tabby who showed
journalists around the consulate in
Istanbul also cleared off madala Seri
the kingdom's former deputy intelligence
chief the journalism watchdog Reporters
Without Borders says justice has been
trampled why the Mohammed bin Salman he
was in contact with toddled copani
just before and after the murder of
Jamal a show she this is what the CIA
based in part its decision that that
Mohammed bin Salman was very high
probability responsible for ordering the
killing so yeah lots and lots of
questions this verdict will do nothing
to quell those questions and it raises
many many more questions there is no
such thing as fair
and open justice in Saudi Arabia despite
intelligence agencies including the CIA
saying Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
was probably involved the White House
shielded the future King from absolute
responsibility and following intense
criticism and skepticism that little
happens in the kingdom without his
knowledge
the Crown Prince eventually had his say
penis like that absolutely not this was
a heinous crime but I take full
responsibility as a leader in Saudi
Arabia the identities of those convicted
were concealed during the closed-door
trial in the capital Riyadh and it
remains unclear what roles they played
in kachelle g's death raising suspicions
that they are the fall guys for much
more powerful Saudis Andrew Chappell al
Jazeera